porque hay un nuevo impasse entre
colombia y venezuela esta vez con la
relación a la migración venezolana
territorio colombiano y es que el
gobierno a nicolás maduro denunciara
ante la onu a colombia por los
asesinatos en tibú de dos jóvenes
venezolanos detenidos cuando
supuestamente robaban en un comercio en
el norte de santander la vicepresidenta
del si rodríguez en su cuenta de twitter
señaló al presidente iván duque es él el
responsable por lo que considera el
exterminio de venezolanos a esto se suma
un nuevo hecho de violencia que dejó 5
muertos entre ellos tres venezolanos
este fin de semana este ataque fue
perpetrado por hombres armados en una
finca en betania en el departamento
colombiano de antioquia por eso tengo
conmigo en el estudio aso ming las heras
investigador adscrito el observatorio de
venezuela de la universidad del rosario
además presidente de la asociación
diálogo ciudadano
colombo-venezolano xiamen buenos días
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa muy buenos días un
placer de estar con ustedes pues le
quiero empezar preguntándole por qué
pasa exactamente con la migración
venezolana colombia además esta
migración que llega a estos
departamentos fronterizos con altos
índices de violencia de pandillas de
grupos armados y cómo se ven ustedes
desde el observatorio
de venezuela de emigración digamos toda
esta problemática que está pasando con
los venezolanos se van a enfrente de la
migración venezolana colombia que se
multiplicó de manera exponencial a
partir del año 2017 es una migración
mixta hay muchos tipos de emigrantes
inmigrantes con más recursos económicos
pero últimamente pues han llegado por
supuesto migrantes con mucho menos
recursos
económicos y bueno han tenido pues que
llegar a zonas a veces también pobres de
los barrios de las ciudades o de las
zonas rurales también entonces
efectivamente es una migración digamos
que de alguna manera pues se ha visto
también afectada por las dinámicas
sociales y de seguridad que existen en
colombia que hace el gobierno de
colombia para proteger esta migración
venezolana además también preguntarle
por exactamente lo que dijo la
vicepresidenta venezolana deisy
rodríguez exterminio venezolanos bueno
evidentemente sea una expresión muy
eficiente muy exagerada no efectivamente
los hechos que a los que se está
refiriendo ellos seguramente son los de
la muerte de de un menor y un joven
venezolano en en el municipio fronterizo
de tibú un hecho realmente lamentable
que tiene que aprender efectivamente las
alarmas porque digamos los hechos
digamos de xenofobia cuando pasan de las
palabras a los hechos pues son son
preocupantes y deben ser atendidos por
la por las sociedades no entonces
efectivamente es un hecho preocupante
que que debe ser debe ser debe ser
atendido pero al mismo tiempo creo que
en colombia pues funciona el estado de
derecho funcionan los tribunales hay una
discusión democrática de esos problemas
y yo creo que que la sociedad colombiana
pues era efectivamente capaz de
abordarlos efectivamente y en este caso
concreto pues también puedes poder
castigar juzgar y castigar a los
culpables de éste
de este hecho también pero ya quiero
preguntar si realmente fue un caso de
xenofobia lo estos dos jóvenes sentidos
porque además tengo entendido que pues
es una práctica que hacen allá a las
personas que encuentran pues robando
como el escarnio público pasearlos por
el pueblo pues sucedió ven en esta
oportunidad con estos migrantes
venezolanos pero realmente eso tuvo que
ver con un caso de xenofobia o más de
violencia o cómo se manejan las cosas en
gente bueno efectivamente es esas
dinámicas no creo que estén
exclusivamente dirigidas a la población
venezolana
efectivamente es así hay hechos de esos
que suceden y hemos tenido noticias
últimamente también de casos parecidos
con población colombiana pero efectiva
es un tema por eso decía que que hay que
abrir las alarmas porque efectivamente
la población venezolana digamos más
empobrecida que de alguna manera ha
podido estar implicada en dinámicas de
este tipo pues ésta es mucho más
vulnerable y está mucho más sujeta a
situaciones de este tipo pero ahí lo
importante es que la institucionalidad
en todo caso como yo decía antes
funcione efectivamente y estos hechos
puedan ser atajado tiempo ahora porque
el gobierno del presidente nicolás
maduro empieza a atacar a colombia en
vez de colaborar con el gobierno
colombiano para pues tratar esta esta
problemática migratoria y además le digo
que por qué no ataca el problema de raíz
en venezuela para que no se produzcan
estas migraciones masivas como la que
además de venezolanos que cada día salen
a buscar una vida mejor en países
vecinos o en otros países también
estamos viendo que hasta eeuu llegan
caminando y pasan toda esa serie de
calamidades porque al gobierno nicolás
maduro no se pone a pensar pues que
hacer no para para detener de raíz este
proceso migratorio forzado yo creo que
aquí bueno esto está enmarcado un poco
dentro de una diplomacia los micrófonos
por un lado y por otro lado también
venezuela están pasando hechos muy
graves por ejemplo la muerte del general
baduel en en prisión es un tema que está
muy oscuro muy poco transparente como se
anunció su muerte verdad entonces
y luego estaba en una una una disputa
muy grande pues que hay en el terreno
internacional
era evidente entre los gobiernos de
bogotá y de caracas no entonces estos
estos temas salen un poco a relucir y se
ponen sobre la mesa como una manera
también un poco de de
esconder con los propios problemas que
existen en venezuela y que son como
todos sabemos efectivamente
muy graves ahora bien como tú lo decías
hay otros hechos que están a quienes en
sobre la mesa por ejemplo la falta de
relaciones diplomáticas
consulares pues también dificulta mucho
esto porque cuando sucede una cosa de
ésta en situaciones normales lo normal
es que los gobiernos y las instituciones
ambos países se puedan poner en contacto
y puedan
investigar aportar información etcétera
para solucionar los problemas y esto en
el caso digamos entre colombia venezuela
hoy en día eso eso es imposible no
entonces esa sería pues una manera
también muy importante de poder abordar
el tema como decía antes
institucionalmente y con tiempo pero
lamentablemente eso no está sucediendo
en un caso de colombia en el suelo hoy
en día saben por qué se crea una observa
de migraciones aquí en colombia no se
preveían de alguna manera que estas
cosas pudieran pasar esta migración
masiva de venezolanos sobre todo acá en
colombia bueno en el observatorio de
venezuela no inicia el rosario y fue
creado hace 16 o 17 años y ya mucho
tiempo con el fin por parte de la
universidad el rosario pues de estudiar
y de seguir los casos de venezuela pero
no solamente por los temas de carácter
migratorio el tema migratorio sobrevino
posteriormente y bueno el los
investigadores de la universidad rosario
pues decidieron incorporarlo por
supuesto a todo a todos los temas que si
bien relacionados con con venezuela y
que impactan de manera muy importante a
colombia por eso una universidad como la
del rosario pues sigue estos temas con
mucha atención